[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Oh, pregnant women
smell so wonderful.
- OK.
- Look at you.
You're huge.
- I'm actually doing
a piece on motherhood.
- Really?
- Did you know amniotic
fluid is actually urine?
- Let's open that wine.
[LAUGHS]
- We're having a baby, too.
Yay.
- How far along are you?
- I'm not actually pregnant.
We have a surrogate.
- I'm Kiki.
I'm Wayne and Tina's
baby's surrogate mom.
- Did you screw the surrogate?
- Whoa.
- Um.
- I think Don is
boning someone else.
- OK, suppose he is.
Do you care?
- Of course I care.
- There are five phases
of a woman's life.
I am in phase four.
You have to be a mother.
- If government
and businesses are
going to devalue
women's work and make
motherhood economically
unfeasible,
why not outsource it?
- See, this is why
people hate liberals.
- Huh.
- I made fresh orange
juice for Karen--
folic acid.
[LAUGHTER]
Tina is like a sperm donor.
- I'm so not like a sperm donor.
- Oh, my god.
I feel so fat.
- Wow.
[END PLAYBACK]
BETHANIE BAYNES: Let's
welcome to the stage
Alysia Reiner, David Alan
Basche, and Madeline Di Nonno.
[APPLAUSE]
Just to get things started,
we celebrated International
Women's Day on Friday.
Did anyone do anything
exciting in celebration?
ALYSIA REINER: I was
shooting, actually,
but at the end of the day,
Liv and I made a video.
I work a lot with
Equality Now, which
is another amazing
organization, and they
asked a lot of different women
to make a video about what
freedom means to them.
And I wanted to wait
and do it with Liv,
so if you check my
Instagram, you're
going to see what
freedom means to me.
Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
That's excellent.
MADELINE DI NONNO: And
we just did so many
corporate presentations.
We did a really large global
presentation for Sony,
for all the divisions of Sony.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Oh, great.
MADELINE DI NONNO: And
then the day before, I
did a big presentation
for CARU, which
is a Children's Advertising
and Online Organization,
so it was a busy
presentation week.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Yeah, I would imagine
it's kind of peak season for
you guys, so that's wonderful.
I actually took the
day off of work.
ALYSIA REINER: That's great.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Not
specifically for that.
It was my father's
birthday, but I
got to see him
spend some quality
time with his granddaughters,
which was incredible.
So great.
So we are here to talk about
this amazing film, "Egg".
And as I said before, I've
watched it a few times,
and every time, I'm
catching more and more
of the complexity
of the characters
and the nuances of,
really, both what
it means to be a woman and
what it means when we consider
or find ourselves faced with
or decide not to move forward
with motherhood, but also
what it means to all of those
around us, so how our
partners perceive it,
how our former friends from
different parts of our lives
perceive our roles.
And there's really just
a ton to unpack there.
But I'd love to hear
from Alysia and David.
Kind of, what brought
you to this project?
ALYSIA REINER: Very quickly,
we did a reading of it
almost 10 years ago.
And I felt when we
did this reading
that it spoke to things.
The characters said things
that I've always thought
but had been afraid to say.
And I loved it so
much, and at that time,
it was-- they were
considering it for the stage.
And I just was like, oh,
my god, I want to do this.
I want to do this.
And then I got really
busy, like, first of all,
making an actual human being,
but then also on "Orange
is the New Black" and
all these other shows.
And two summers ago, we were on
a ferry boat from Fire Island,
and I only bring
that up, because it
was from the town of Kismet,
so it was actually Kismet.
And we bumped into the
writer, and she said,
I just did a rewrite on the
screenplay version of it.
Would you like to read it?
And we were both like, yes.
And I felt, more than
ever, it was these things
that no one was talking about--
about the relationship between
work and art and commerce
and parenthood and
career and friendship.
And, you know, I was
talking to someone recently
about how we're changing so much
in reference to gender norms
and how we talk about gender.
And yet we haven't made those
changes around parenthood
and how we talk about
the roles of parenthood.
And we have such an
antiquated version
of what a mother
and a father is,
and it just hasn't caught
up to our world today.
And I wanted to bring
up some of those issues.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Yeah, what she said.
It had stuck with us.
I mean it was-- we--
we're actors by trade,
and we both make a living
as actors, which is great.
You know, Alysia
and another partner
produced the Wall Street--
the female-driven Wall
Street movie called "Equity."
and I had just finished
five years on a sitcom,
and I thought I had a break.
And Alysia said, hey, you're
going to produce this with us.
You get to be the associate
producer, and I said,
what the hell is that?
It turns out that he runs around
putting out all the fires.
ALYSIA REINER: Correct.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
So I learned that.
And then we really
weren't necessarily
sure we wanted to
produce anything again,
but then we met the
writer on the ferry,
and there was "Egg" again.
And we said, oh,
man, it's so good.
And I-- as a man, I love
the male characters in it.
I love what the male
characters have to say.
You know, I was
excited about it,
even if it-- even if it's quote,
unquote, female-driven content.
You know, I was all in.
So when something sticks
with you like that, you know,
you got to do it.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah,
it's interesting to hear
that it was like a
multi-year process and just
kind of sticking in until
it finds its final form.
ALYSIA REINER: And I'll
also say, for me, I like--
as a producer, I need to--
I don't produce
something, unless I
feel like it needs a voice.
You know, there's a lot
of stories that I'll read,
and I'll be like, that's
amazing, but I know some--
I know this will get produced.
Like I know someone
will do this.
This is one of those
where I was like,
I feel like too
many people would
be afraid to make this movie.
And I wanted to be
the one who wasn't
afraid to make this movie.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
I'm glad you did.
That actually is a
great segue, Madeline.
I would love to hear from
the lens of the Geena Davis
Institute, why was this film
so important to your mission?
Building off what
Alysia is saying
is that there was
probably-- a lot of people
who would pass on this,
because it's not something that
is obvious to be spoken about.
And why is that just even more
important to be spoken about?
MADELINE DI NONNO:
It's important in terms
of on-screen, behind
the camera, which
I'd love for Alysia and David
to talk about it, and you know,
there's a social imperative.
So how do we take these
kind of societal norms
and turn them upside down,
which they did beautifully.
But from a business
imperative, we just
did a benchmark study, which
looked at 10 years of films,
family films--
G, PG, PG-13.
And what we found is
over the past decade,
female-centric films generated
55% more at the box office.
And that change
happened in 2016,
where female-centric films
generated 7% more at the box
office, and in 2017, it was
38% more at the box office.
So there's the
social imperative,
which we're talking about.
But there's the
business imperative.
So it's really,
really important.
But yet, even still, female
lead characters-- there's
still a 2 to 1 ratio
of male characters
to female characters.
So that's not what happened
in the case of "Egg",
so it's really important.
And then I'd love to
throw to you to talk about
behind the camera.
ALYSIA REINER: So
our third partner
on this, Michele Ganeless, who
was the president of Comedy
Central and who had
left and was looking
into producing her
own stuff and who
has now started a great
production company as well--
this was her first piece
off of Comedy Central.
And the thing that I loved
about Michelle from the get-go--
or we loved about
Michelle from the get-go--
was that she was equally
committed to hiring
all women across the board.
So we hired all female heads
of every single department,
so we have--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: For example--
ALYSIA REINER: For example, a
female writer, female director,
female cinematographer.
And I love to talk about
her, because she had never
shot a feature, not because
she wasn't insanely talented,
but because no one had
given her the opportunity.
And I saw a short she did
in Africa with children
and a leopard, and
they say, like,
the two things you
should never do
are work with
animals and children.
And she did this spectac--
I mean the film is
spectacularly beautiful.
But this was her first
feature, and now she's
shot like three more
in the past two years.
And--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Female sound designer.
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah,
female sound design.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: [INAUDIBLE].
ALYSIA REINER: Female--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Set designer.
ALYSIA REINER: Set designer.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Wardrobe.
ALYSIA REINER: Wardrobe.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: They
had a female camera op.
ALYSIA REINER: Makeup, yeah.
Camera op, yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Production coordinator.
ALYSIA REINER:
Everything, so editor.
So we did all female heads
of all departments, and then
70% female crew.
And that felt amazing,
and yes, the women
made as much, if not
more, than the men.
And it felt amazing, and one of
the things that I love to say
is there was way less drama
than any other set I've ever
been on.
If we have that--
the gender norms of,
like, women are dramatic
and throw a hissy fit,
whatever-- did not happen.
There was no drama.
We finished our days on
time or early every day,
and we were shooting sometimes
like eight pages a day.
And it was an
incredible experience,
and I think my favorite part
was the emails from women
and young women who this was
their first job on a set,
and they wrote to us
afterwards and said,
like, I've been on a couple of
sets, and it's not like "Egg".
Even our production
designer recently wrote us,
and she's like, I still
haven't had another experience
like "Egg".
And they said, I haven't--
like, other sets
weren't like this.
But you gave me hope.
And you made me feel like I
can create that in the future.
Like when I'm the boss,
I'm going to do that,
and I'm going to
hire more women.
And that's really
why I'm sitting
up here with this woman is
because way before I made
this movie, way before I
made movies, she inspired me,
and the Geena Davis
Institute inspired me about
if you can see it, you can
be, both onscreen and off.
And that is so deeply important.
I'll never forget when I first
heard the statistic of when
you watch anything, even a
cartoon, 77% of the characters
are male, which means any
girl watching any media feels
like she's a minority.
Like, that's a
ridiculous concept.
Women are 50% of the
population, but no matter
what they're watching, when
they're watching any screen,
they feel like a minority.
MADELINE DI NONNO: And just
to add some context to that,
our friends at
Common Sense Media
do a lot of analyses
on media consumption.
So your average tween
in the United States
is engaging and watching media
upwards of six hours a day,
and teens are still
engaging with media
and watching about
nine hours a day.
It's more than sleeping, school,
anything else they're doing.
So when you think about media
impressions, and you think
about the repetitiveness and
how it's being reinforced,
they're seeing that stereotyped
media image over and over
and over.
And it does make an impact on
how they view the world, how
they view each other.
So it's very significant.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Actually,
I have a question for you
on that, because we
were talking earlier.
I feel like I'm starting to
see more female leads, more
female-driven.
We're starting to see a lot
of female superhero movies.
Is this the case of being
hungry and seeing signs
for food all the time,
or are we really seeing
a shift in the industry?
MADELINE DI NONNO: Well, in
terms of this benchmark study
that we just did, you know,
unfortunately, 10 years later,
it's still a 2 to 1 ratio of
male leads to female leads.
And women are 52% of
the moviegoing audience,
and we're 51% of the population.
So we're not really
being represented.
And when we talk about people
of color, people of color
are 38% of the US population,
but in terms of the past decade
of film, there's only 16.7%.
And then if you really want to
get into the intersectionality
of it, which is a really
important conversation,
people with disabilities,
people who identify as LGBTQ
are less than 1%
of any character
in a film over
the past 10 years,
the top 100 films from
the United States.
So we have a lot of work to do.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
I'm glad you guys
are doing the work.
There's another interesting
facet to the film,
where, Alysia, your
character, Tina,
is financially leading
the partnership.
It comes up in a way in a
couple different conversations
that she is leading the
household from a contribution
perspective.
Yet she's spun as kind
of not being woman enough
or not being nurturing enough.
And when you compare that
with Kiki's character, who
is very needy and
very dependent,
and you know, the
men-- sorry, David--
are like tripping over
themselves to take care of her,
talk about that, a little
bit about that storyline.
ALYSIA REINER: I think you
should talk about that.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah,
talk about it, David.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Yeah, I think--
I believe the line in the film,
where Tina, Alysia's character,
is accused of not being
nurturing and kind of comparing
the women in the room.
And she says, I'm not nurturing?
And she says, look at her.
She's a fucking train wreck.
Right?
And the power of the
powerless woman--
no man can resist.
ALYSIA REINER: And
additionally, my character,
you find out in that moment,
is supporting her husband.
And like, how is
that not nurturing?
And she says, like,
look, I support--
you wanted to do this.
I supported that.
You wanted to do this.
You want to do this.
I supported that.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
It's never enough.
It was never enough, and
that's an interesting thing.
And it is fascinating to
see the shift in society.
We were talking
about this earlier
from women who are
breadwinners in their family
and make more money
than their husbands do.
And in this case, I think it
was one of the things I really
liked about the film when I
read it, even before we made it,
was, Don, my character
is very happy
to be the wealthiest
person in the room.
He's fairly certain of
that, even though none of us
know anything about anyone.
Right?
He makes that assumption.
And he's perfectly
fine with that.
And that gives him power over
people, especially over women.
And so it's a very
interesting thing to see,
when a woman is an artist,
self-assured, financially
stable, financially independent,
and speaks her mind, you know,
it's fascinating
to hear what people
have had to say about that
character in the film.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
And I like that.
And I've-- Don judges
everyone in the room,
and we're all judging
everyone all the time,
but a little more so.
That's what makes it fun.
And Don gives voice to some
of the stereotypical misogyny
that we're hearing all the time.
And I don't like him,
but I liked the chance
to do that so that people
would go, ugh, or people go,
oh, he didn't just say that.
Did he just say that?
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
ALYSIA REINER: There have
been a lot of audible groans--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah.
ALYSIA REINER: --when Don says--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: I get
very happy about those, yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Well, I have to--
just knowing you, I was--
I mean it was just making
me laugh at every turn,
because it was so antithetical
to who you are, but it was--
it's almost like-- and
because it takes place
in this loft throughout the
film, mostly in this main area,
you kind of get this
insular feeling of almost
being in somebody's head.
And you have all the different
judgments or different aspects
of what could be firing off,
and there's a tremendous amount
of judgment.
And it's coming
across both genders,
and it's coming across
different parenting decisions,
and it really--
to that end, I'm
curious, did you guys
have to let go of any of
your preconceived notions
coming into this film in order
to portray these characters?
Like, how was that for you?
That's a juicy one.
ALYSIA REINER: I know.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: I mean yes.
I mean yes, right?
As actors, we always
do, because we're not--
unless we're playing
ourselves, then we
have our own
preconceived notions.
But character-- characters
that you inhabit always
have preconceived notions.
Sometimes that's your way in.
Sometimes that--
I mean with Don,
honestly, he's such a judgmental
asshole that I was like,
ah, got it.
I know that guy.
BETHANIE BAYNES: I
know that guy, yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah,
we all know that guy.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: But we
may work with some of them.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Maybe.
I don't know.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Probably
not here at Google.
BETHANIE BAYNES: I don't know.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Not here at Google,
but we all know those guys.
And I had-- yeah, I mean-- and
honestly, I was on-- again,
I was on a set that was 70%
female and fairly invisible,
unless I was in
front of the camera.
And I don't-- and
that's not a criticism.
It's not a complaint.
And so I had to set aside
my preconceived notion of,
oh, well, I'm a man, and
I'm producing a movie,
and I'm one of the big bosses.
Everybody's going
to, come on now.
Let's do what I say to do.
Fall in line.
Not that-- I guess not
that I was ever that guy.
But I was in a room
full of smart women.
ALYSIA REINER: But I
think-- but that's actually.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: And things
were getting taken care of,
and I was kind of like, it's OK.
If I don't have to--
Alysia was talking about drama.
Like, I don't have to yell.
I don't have to be typically
male or loud to get
things done.
Things seem to be happening
just fine, and it's OK.
If I'm not seeing, it's because
there's no problems, no fire
to put out.
So I had to kind
of adjust what I
thought my role was going to
be as producer in that way,
I guess.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Was
that change, to you,
the dynamic of the set and the
dynamic of the relationships?
Was that palpable to you
as well from previous films
you've been on?
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Oh, yeah.
Oh, for sure.
Yeah.
ALYSIA REINER: You know, I
love that you brought that up,
because, for me, as
an actor playing Tina,
like Tina has a lot
more preconceived
notions and judgment and her
way of doing things than I do.
Like, I think, as a human
being, one of my biggest goals
is to sort of strip away
as many biases as I can,
because that makes
me a more open artist
and more able to play
the widest variety.
It also makes life
more interesting.
I'm just much more--
I find life much more
fun if you're really
willing to listen and wonder.
Our production company is called
[? 2 ?] [? Wonder Full ?] to Be
Limited, like two
people full of wonder.
And my biggest goal as I grow
and age is to keep wondering.
Like, I feel like people tend
to get more and more narrow,
and they hang on to their
beliefs more and more
as they age, whereas small
humans are much more like,
I wonder.
Oh, I don't know.
And I want to stay
in that wonder place
as long as possible.
And I think Tina feels
like she knows things
a lot more than I do.
But in reference to
the dynamic of the set,
it was very surprising
I think to everyone.
And I didn't realize
what a white male I
was married to until we
were in this dynamic,
BETHANIE BAYNES: Because--
by the way, they're married.
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah.
He's a really evolved
feminist white male,
but you put him in a room
with a lot of powerful women,
and he's still a white man.
And he still can fall--
like, we all as women
can fall in to
seeing him as such.
And he still can fall into
those stereotypical roles.
We all fall into our roles
sometimes on and off camera
without realizing it.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yep.
Actually, let's roll-- we
have a couple of clips.
Let's roll the first clip here.
TINA: I forgot, I'm not--
I'm not actually pregnant.
We have a surrogate mother.
KAREN: Oh?
DON: Oh.
KAREN: Oh.
Wow.
TINA: Yeah.
WAYNE: Yeah.
KAREN: Oh, a surrogate?
TINA: Yeah.
KAREN: We know a gay
couple who did that.
DON: We do?
KAREN: Yeah, the guy who
did our window treatments.
DON: OK.
KAREN: Did you have
to go through all
that awful IVF fertility stuff?
TINA: No.
KAREN: Well, that's good.
TINA: Yeah, no.
I can't-- I mean we can.
This was more of an option.
KAREN: OK.
TINA: A-- a-- sort of
a utopian pregnancy.
KAREN: A utopian pregnancy?
TINA: It's sort of
dismantling and restructuring
of the traditional family
unit, a redistribution of rules
to a more shared
economy kind of thing.
WAYNE: Kind of.
TINA: You're the first
people we've told.
We don't really have
the rap down yet.
DON: So you can have
the baby yourself?
TINA: Right, yes.
We can.
We choose not to.
DON: You're paying someone
to have the baby for you?
TINA: Yeah.
DON: Perfect.
[LAUGHTER]
BETHANIE BAYNES: So I love--
I love this clip,
because you come up
with the notion of language.
Like, we don't have
the rap down yet.
And I think this is
something that we all
have these judgments.
We all have these
opinions that we
bring with us into,
certainly, family dynamics
and this assumption of
how things should be
or how they can roll
off the tongue or not.
And when we tend to
go outside those lines
with what we expect,
that's where we really
start to get tongue tied.
And that's why I love the
vulnerability of showcasing
your character just
working through that
with exactly the judgments
that you would expect.
What?
Huh?
Why?
What?
You know, talk to
me a little bit
about the importance
of that language.
ALYSIA REINER: Language is
such an interesting thing,
and as an artist,
there are some writers,
for example, who are very
specific about language.
Aaron Sorkin doesn't
want you to change
a single word or a
period, and other writers
are much more open.
Risa, our writer in
this, was somewhat open,
but interestingly
enough, our director
didn't want us to change a word.
She's like-- she felt-- and
she's written and directed
things.
And in this case, she
was just the director,
and she felt that the writing
was so precise that she didn't
want us to change
a thing, and she
didn't want us to improv a lot.
But she wanted it
to feel like improv.
So that moment
that you just saw,
even though I'm floundering for
the words, that's actually--
that was all written as such.
And language-- in
our culture, I think
we are in this
moment where we don't
have language for a lot of
what's going on in the world.
And we're creating new language.
You know, when I was growing
up there was no such thing
as gender fluid and non-binary
and we have a 10-year-old,
and that is such--
it just is for her.
And that's-- and that's such
a beautiful, miraculous thing,
because we, as a
culture, are evolving.
But this, as I said earlier,
the way we handle parent roles
has not evolved.
Like my daughter knows how to
describe her gender fluidity so
much better than we
as a culture know
how to describe parenthood.
And that's, to me,
a problem and part
of what we were
looking to delve into.
And sometimes it's my deepest
hope-- why I'm an artist--
is that we can
express these things
and delve into them
in art as a way
to bring up conversation to
then move our society forward.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Yeah, and I think
you were alluding to that, too,
when I'm thinking back to you
guys on the boat, of
this being a story
that some people would shy
away from, because it does
unpack those things.
And you can even
see the characters
questioning themselves.
Am I happy?
Is this what I wanted?
Was that decision the
right decision for me?
And you know, it's just
regular human, that grappling.
And I think we don't
see so much of that.
I mean certainly, Madeline,
within the industry,
where there's a lot of glamor
and sheen to everything,
we don't see the
characters really
crumble as much on
these definitive parts
of their lives.
Do you have any
thoughts on that?
MADELINE DI NONNO: Well, when we
look at attributes and careers,
only 15% of female
characters in TV and film--
and this is from our 2018 data,
which we haven't published
yet--
are shown working.
And then--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: 15?
MADELINE DI NONNO: 15%
just showing working.
And when you look
at, also, the ages
of the mother, which
is another thing,
in the movie, most
female characters
are shown in their teens.
Most of them are shown under 19.
Only 30% are shown in their
40s, and only 3% in their 50s.
And so when you think
about motherhood and women
having children at
an older age, that's
not something that's really
being reflected in the media.
And then when you think about
kind of the caretaking of it,
there's very few men
depicted as caretaking.
And when they are, you see
a lot of the bumbling dad.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: The
bumbling [INAUDIBLE]..
MADELINE DI NONNO:
You know, the silly--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Not doing it well.
MADELINE DI NONNO:
--lazy, bumbling dad.
And we know from our
friends at Promundo--
I happen to sit on their board--
that changing the
dynamics of masculinity
and really reflecting
that in the media
is important, because
most American fathers
want to spend more time.
I think it's nearly
70% want to spend
more time with their children.
And that's their
data, not our data.
So media is not
really keeping up
with how our
society is changing.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yes.
You are preaching to
the choir [INAUDIBLE]..
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: What do
the other 30% of the dads
want to be doing, by the way?
Just curious.
MADELINE DI NONNO:
Well, what we--
well, it's funny.
When we did an adv-- a study
on gender bias in advertising,
48% of the female
characters in ads
were most likely to
be in the kitchen,
and the men were at sporting
events and driving around
in cars.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Of
course [INAUDIBLE]..
MADELINE DI NONNO: So
that's where they were--
driving around.
BETHANIE BAYNES: What
they're doing, yes.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: I don't
own a car, so we'll get there.
We'll get there.
BETHANIE BAYNES: We
have one more clip.
Go ahead with clip number two.
DON: I can see why
you guys chose her.
KIKI: Oh, shut up.
TINA: I'll get you
something to put on.
KIKI: Hi.
I'm Kiki.
I'm Wayne and Tina's
baby's surrogate mom.
And you are?
KAREN: I'm Karen.
KIKI: You're
pregnant, too, right?
KAREN: Oh, no.
I'm not pregnant.
I'm kidding.
KIKI: Oh, god.
Good.
It's always so horrible
when you ask someone
if they're pregnant, and then
it just turns out that they're
just, you know, fat.
KAREN: Oh, well, I'm
pregnant and fat.
KIKI: Oh, god.
No, no, no.
I didn't mean that you're--
uh, sorry.
I know.
I mean, obviously,
you're pregnant.
WAYNE: But doesn't
she look wonderful?
KIKI: Yeah, you have
such rosy cheeks.
TINA: Here.
KIKI: Oh, thank you.
ALYSIA REINER: Awkward.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yes, so
awkward, but also so relatable.
And I just-- I think there's
so much packed into that one
exchange, whether it's the body
shaming, hypersexualization
of Kiki, and then
there's the question
of whether is she
pregnant, or is she fat,
and why does it matter?
And why is this a public thing
when women are carrying that,
and it's all they can
talk to you about?
There's so much packed
into that one exchange.
Tell us-- tell us
about the scene.
ALYSIA REINER: Well, it's funny.
I was-- I did an evening--
I'm totally going
off on a tangent,
because everyone's
going to watch the movie
or watched it already, right?
BETHANIE BAYNES: That's right.
ALYSIA REINER: Oh, man.
I don't want to
give anything away.
But I did a--
with Time's Up, I
produced an evening
about Rebecca Traister's
book, or inspired
by Rebecca's Traister's
book, "Good and Mad," which
all of you should read.
It's really the history of
rage and female rage and anger.
And I did it, honestly, because
I'm afraid of my own anger.
I'm afraid of anger,
and so when I--
in that wondering way,
when I find something
that I'm afraid
of and that makes
me have a pit in my stomach,
I'm like, go towards that,
and go explore it.
So we did this evening, and we
had a lot of different women
find a passage about rage
or raging to express.
And so we had a comedian, who
I love, because she's a woman,
obviously.
She is disabled,
and she is Muslim.
And so she, like--
she is one of the most
amazing women I know.
And she does a comedy
bit about being pregnant
and about how you never should
ask anyone if they're pregnant
ever, because--
or parents, because
people will tell you.
Like, they will show you the
baby pictures before you can
even ask, so you never even--
and it's not even just pregnant.
It's parenthood, because we
assume that all women want
to be parents, and
that's a really big topic
of this movie is not all
women want to be parents.
Not all men want to be
parents, and that's OK.
A woman is enough, whether
she's a mother or not.
She's more than enough, and
that we've created this standard
and this norm that is completely
inappropriate and lets
go of any choice for women.
And that's what
enraged me about it,
and it was another thing
that made me really
want to make this movie is
I want women to have free--
all women to have
freedom of choice
in a full and complete way.
So that's, for me, what
that moment is about.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
Yeah, I think it's
interesting how
you see the characters
evolve from pushing
each other to each
other's edge and then
really coming to each other's
rescue at the same time.
And I think there's,
obviously, the motherhood
and the parenthood
topic, but there's
a lot to feminine relationships
that's explored as well.
And I found that
really, really powerful.
ALYSIA REINER: That's-- I mean
that's my favorite thing about
the movie is these two women--
you know, Kiki aside, sort of--
who are old friends
and really believe
deeply different things, have
made deeply different choices,
but are willing to
lovingly accept and listen
to each other's choices
without making the other
make the same choice.
And that, to me, is what true,
authentic friendship is about.
And it was another reason why
this was so deeply important
for me to make as a filmmaker
in this moment, because it was--
we read the script in October.
The man people call President
became president in January,
and I met Christina
at the Women's March.
And-- which was the weekend
of the inauguration.
And I found out that she
was childless by choice,
and I thought, wow,
how interesting
to make this movie
in this moment
when women feel like
an endangered species.
And additionally, when
53% of white women
voted for that human being--
it's a little bit of a
Voldemort thing for me--
I realized I wanted to also
make art about people listening
to each other, even if they
didn't believe the same thing.
And that's incredibly important
to me in this moment--
learning how to listen
without judgment,
or even if you're judging, shut
the fuck up, and try and really
listen and learn something,
and ask as many questions,
and try and really
open up your heart
to, what can I relate to here?
What can I possibly
relate to here?
And I think these two women do
a really magical job of that.
And that, to me, is what the
story, the core of the story
became.
And it wasn't what--
I didn't know that that's
what it really was deeply,
most deeply about
until the editing room,
really, but in watching
the edit, it was like,
oh, it's really about being
willing to listen and support,
even if you don't necessarily
believe the same thing.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Right.
Yeah, I think that
definitely came
through-- in particular,
the scenes with just the two
of them.
That was very strong.
I'm curious of your
take on that clip
we just watched in terms of
what you saw there from your--
MADELINE DI NONNO: Well,
there's a few things.
There's one clip that was in--
a little bit of it in the
trailer, where Kiki talks
about the five phases
of being a woman.
And the second phase
is boobs, teens.
And she talks about, that's
when you have your most power.
But I'm in the fourth phase,
and I have to be just a mother.
And then there's the other
scene, where you first
see Kiki, and you completely
see her actually objectified.
And so when I think about
that, and I think about some
of our new data,
female characters
are six times more likely
to be hypersexualized
and five times more likely
to be verbally objectified.
And I thought-- and maybe
you can just talk about it.
But there's scenes
in the movie that
do it with such great humor
and kind of point fun at it,
but truly, that's what
we're seeing in our--
in all of our family films.
So I don't know if you want to--
ALYSIA REINER:
Yeah, it definitely
was taking a ribbing at it.
And that five phases--
I'm obsessed with that
five phase dialogue.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
No, it's so-- yes.
You have to watch the movie.
ALYSIA REINER: One of
the most brilliant things
I've ever read, and Anna
Camp does a genius job of it.
And she-- I love that character
so much, because she really--
she's kind of doing
it to herself.
Like her choices
as a human being,
the character's choices
are so fascinating,
and the patterns
she's going into, and
without ruining too much,
but she's in a relationship
with a married man.
And these patterns
that we fall into
and her choice of
what she wears,
which is written into
the script, and we just
followed that lead
that, in a way,
she is choosing this stereotype
and this paradigm of what
a woman is.
And it's the diametric
opposite to what
Tina is, because Tina is really
interested in sort of breaking
all those stereotypes.
And then Wayne's
in between trying
to sort of navigate
these two women, which
makes it all interesting.
BETHANIE BAYNES: That's a
very complex part of it, too,
because each character--
David said earlier about
Don, we all know that guy.
Each character-- we all
know that character.
There's someone in our lives,
or there was a time in our lives
where we felt like we subscribed
to various similar paradigms.
So I definitely
feel like there's
that sense of identification
that you can have through each
of those characters.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: It's also
every dinner party we've all
ever been to gone wrong.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: And usually--
I mean I think we've all been
to those dinner parties, where
someone says something
a little bit off,
and most eyes just kind
of go to the plate,
or someone gets an elbow
under the table or a kick,
and that's it.
Right?
And then you just rip it
apart on the way home.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Right.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Right.
Like on the subway ride home,
I can't believe she said that.
I'm like, I know.
What's her problem?
Well, she's never had to
work a day in her life,
so she doesn't ba-ba-ba.
And he's ba-ba-ba,
and we all do that.
And but we do there.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: We don't
do do it on the ride home.
We do it there.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Right.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: It's
like we're at the table,
and someone says, why
would you say that to me?
The other person says, well,
because I think you're x.
And the person says,
you don't know me.
I'm not- why would you say that?
Like, this is an idea of how
we want to live our lives,
and the person says, well,
I don't agree with that.
So it's-- we get to live out
that dinner party fantasy that
we've all had of, wouldn't it
be great if we could just tell
him, like nobody likes to
hear you talk about XYZ?
We don't give a
shit, and you don't
seem to care about people.
Like, it's that
dinner party thing
that I think that we've
all wanted to talk about
with subjects that we've
all wanted to talk about,
but are a little bit afraid
to, like we just said
earlier, or very afraid to.
And I think that's part of--
I hope that's part of
what happens in the film.
We've been hearing from a lot
of people who have seen it
that they have questions.
They want to talk--
why did we do it this way?
Why did we do it that way?
Well, you know,
and that's great.
That's what we want.
It's not ab-- you don't
watch it and be like, eh.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Pretty little bow and--
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES: It's
not one of those.
It sits with you.
ALYSIA REINER: And a
lot of people have said,
I went back and watched
it a bunch of times,
and every time, it's different.
I see different things.
And that's really
exciting and rewarding.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Well,
there's a moment--
there's a scene where,
as Dave is describing,
it's uncomfortable.
It's almost like, I
think this way sometimes
when you watch Ben
Stiller's comedies.
You're like, no, don't,
don't, don't do that.
It's uncomfortable to
watch, because it puts you
in that position where you feel
that vulnerability of sharing
something that you
normally would just
keep to yourself or share with
your partner on the way home.
But there's one
scene where there's
a question that comes out, and
David, your character, Don,
just goes, well, that's
a little personal.
Meanwhile, we're talking about
the most personal things ever,
but there's that
dry humor to it.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
It was about money.
It was a question about money.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Oh,
right, right, right.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Does your
boyfriend pay your rent?
Like, why do you have to
move out of your apartment?
And we've just talked
about her uterus, her life,
her relationship, her identity
as a woman, and then I say--
someone says, well, why do
you have to buy the apartment?
And I say, well, that's
a little personal.
We don't want to get into that.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Well, that
unfolds a whole other--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Money is a whole other--
BETHANIE BAYNES: Thinking
back to your last project
with "Equity," one
of your past projects
with "Equity" is just that
comfort around women and money
and certainly women and
money as portrayed in media.
And we talked a little bit
about breadwinning women
and primary earning women
who are 42% of our nation,
and we're not seeing that
showcased on screen anywhere.
We're not seeing that pride,
and we're not seeing [INAUDIBLE]
ALYSIA REINER: That's
my next project.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yes.
Love it.
Yeah, so that's a great segue.
What's up next for you guys
that you're able to share?
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Is there
a part in your next project
for me?
That's great.
ALYSIA REINER: No,
there are no men in it.
No.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: That's OK.
ALYSIA REINER: Right now,
I'm shooting "The Deuce,"
which is so much fun.
Oh, my god.
We're--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Season three?
ALYSIA REINER: Last season
was-- yeah, season two,
we shot in-- it was the '70s.
And now, in season three,
it's the '80s in New York.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Oh, the costumes.
ALYSIA REINER: The
writing is so genius,
and I'm so, so, so enjoying it.
And "Better Things,"
which I'm also on, just
started airing like two
weeks ago, I think this week.
Sharon Stone is our guest star.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Ooh.
MADELINE DI NONNO:
That's terrific.
ALYSIA REINER: I have a
gorgeous scene with her.
She was such a joy to work with.
And--
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: I'm going to
cro-- just to keep things even,
I'm going to cross [INAUDIBLE].
Men could do that, too.
ALYSIA REINER: And we
just wrapped season seven
of "Orange," and they never tell
us when that's going to be out.
But my guess is summer,
but don't quote me.
That could be a lie.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
And this is the--
is this the final season?
ALYSIA REINER: This
is our final season.
That's for sure.
And I've definitely been
mourning that a little bit.
BETHANIE BAYNES: I was going
to say, how does that feel?
That's a lifetime.
ALYSIA REINER: It hurts.
You know, I'll
miss the character,
because she was
so extraordinary.
And this season is quite
epic in its social commentary
on what's going on in
the world right now.
I'm really proud to be part of
this season for that reason.
And-- but more
than anything, I'll
miss the people, because there
are some spectacular humans
both behind and in
front of the camera, who
made that all happen.
And I will love them forever,
and I'll see them forever,
but I won't see them as much.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yeah.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Not behind bars.
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
No, hopefully not.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah, well.
BETHANIE BAYNES: I
mean we never know.
She's still curious.
David, what's up next for you?
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: If Alysia
hires me in her next project,
then I'll tell you what
that is when we get there.
I just did a show on CBS called
"Instinct," and that was fun.
And yeah, trying to get a
job and being a hands-on dad.
BETHANIE BAYNES: That's
the most important job.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE:
Which I'm very proud of,
and Alysia's a
hands-on mom, but she's
been a lot busier than
I have, especially
since "Egg" came out.
So yeah, I'm doing laundry
and the dishes and being a dad
and--
BETHANIE BAYNES: And
you're building tree forts.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah,
we did build the treehouse.
There were power tools involved,
so a little more stereotypical,
but yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
Big shoes to fill.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Madeline,
what does your season
look like coming up with--
MADELINE DI NONNO: We have
a really rich research year.
We're just about to publish
the next iteration of what
we call the GDIQ,
which was generously
funded by Google.org.
It stands for the Geena
Davis Inclusion Quotient,
and it's a machine learning tool
that automates gender, screen
and speaking time, and
actually race for screen time
using audio and
facial recognition.
So we have a really rich
partnership with Google,
so we're really
grateful for that.
And this year, we're
releasing not only film, which
we have done, but also TV.
So that's been really important
for us to evolve the GDIQ.
So that's coming
out soon for us.
And then, as I mentioned,
we're partnering with Promundo
on a masculinity study.
We're also partnering
with Plan International
on a study about girls'
relationship to leadership.
So we have a lot of really
interesting research projects
coming out.
And then we also
are commissioned
to do a lot of research.
So we've done a lot of
research for leading brands,
content creators, studios.
So behind the scenes,
a lot of people
want to know how they're doing,
and so we'll also conduct
a lot of research that way.
BETHANIE BAYNES:
That's so important.
I'm so glad to hear it.
We are a data-driven
company here at Google,
and I think the more you
have data telling a story,
while it may not be the
story we all want to hear,
it's telling a certain
story, and only then can
you start to see action and
start to measure the progress.
It's very, very important
work that you're doing.
I'm thrilled that we're finding
ways to partner together
on that initiative.
So "Egg" is available on Amazon
and iTunes and Video On Demand.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Coming
up on Hulu as of March 31.
BETHANIE BAYNES: On
Hulu, March 31st.
ALYSIA REINER: It's a great
Mother's or Father's Day gift.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yes, exactly.
We actually flipped Mother's
and Father's Day in my house,
so I get Father's Day.
My husband gets Mother's Day.
ALYSIA REINER: Nice.
MADELINE DI NONNO:
And for anyone
who's watching the
global channel,
aren't you coming
out internationally?
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yes.
ALYSIA REINER: Yes.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Yeah,
we're premiering in the UK
March 31st.
ALYSIA REINER: March 31st,
we open in theaters, which
is Mother's Day in the UK.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: UK, Ireland,
New Zealand, Australia.
ALYSIA REINER: It's actually
called something else there.
It's called "Motherhood."
BETHANIE BAYNES: I
wasn't sure if you
were going to share that yet,
so for our UK subscribers
and counterparts, make sure
that you keep an eye out
for "Motherhood."
ALYSIA REINER: And if
you follow @alysiareiner,
you'll get all the
scoop about it always.
BETHANIE BAYNES: The updates.
ALYSIA REINER: Yeah.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Yes, and for
the Geena Davis Institute,
anybody that wants
to learn more,
there's some great
infographics throughout there.
I do just think some of the data
just really makes you mindful,
and that can be
found at seejane.org.
So thank you all so much.
This was such a
great conversation,
and we're really looking
forward to more success to come.
MADELINE DI NONNO: Thank you.
BETHANIE BAYNES: Thank you.
DAVID ALAN BASCHE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]